[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'objectif demeure phillips et de
reprendre le contrôle
permettez moi de vous dire que dans un
an vous et moi nous constaterons que la
reprise du contrôle de l'immigration
massive en france n'a pas du tout été
reprise c'est pour moi une évidence pour
trois raisons d'abord on ne fait rien
sur le regroupement familial est la
suède l'allemagne l'ont fait on a fait
l'inversé
on a ouvert avec la loi de gérard
collomb dit diana deuxième chose sur le
droit d'asile
on ne fait rien de plus de ce qu'a fait
l'allemagne et beaucoup d'autres pays et
l'immigration pour les soins la m dans
quelques semaines sénat proposera à
nouveau de transformer la m
en aide médicale d'urgence le
gouvernement refusera donc tant qu'on ne
traite pas les causes et bien donc on
aura l'immigration massive
je précise que quand on parle des quotas
on parle de l'immigration
professionnelle
c'est grosso modo 10 % en 2000 sur les
200 milles et 306 séjour new hâlas
melons dès qu'on dénombre 300 mille
bénéficiaires faut aussi traiter lacaune
la question de l'immigration clandestine
il faut faire attention chaque fois il
ya le boeuf qui est fait lorsqu'on
travaille plus finement sur les
propositions s'aperçoit que derrière
tout ça les propositions sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
moi aujourd'hui j'attends aussi nous
attendons aussi des mesures sur
l'immigration familiale sur des
migrations clandestines sur le problème
aujourd'hui des trafics des réseaux
mafieux sur la difficulté aujourd'hui
que nous avons à traiter les dossiers de
demandeurs d'asile sur l'absence de
suivi de ses deux mandats
sur ces questions qui sont à mes yeux
est à nos yeux les plus importantes
il n'y a toujours pas de réponse
j'attends les actes je ne veux plus de
discours je ne veux plus de propos je ne
veux plus d'un tentation je veux un
texte ça suffit maintenant que ce soit
sur la sécurité ce soit sur
l'immigration on veut des années